CANDIDATES ASIDE.
I WANT TO COME BACK RIGHT HERE
IN WASHINGTON.
THE FIRST OFFICIAL RESPONSE FROM
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND WRITING
ME NO SCHOOLS OF LEE,
MERCEDES SCHLAPP, TRUMP SR.
CAMPAIGN ADVISOR.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE DIRECTOR OF
STRATEGIC COMMS.
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT ANYONE
TONIGHT?
>> IT IS QUITE AN ENTERTAINING
NIGHT.
WE ARE STARTING TO SEE IS THE
DIVIDE AMONG DEMOCRATS WHERE YOU
HAVE GOVERNORS SAYING WAIT A
SECOND.
THESE POLICIES ARE WAY TOO
RADICAL FOR AMERICA AND WE CAN'T
FORCE IT DOWN HER THROAT.
THEY ARE ADMITTING TO IT
THERE ARE ADMITTING, SOME ARE
ADMITTING THE DEMOCRAT PARTY IS
GOING FAR LEFT AND THAT'S WHERE
YOU'RE STARTING TO SEE THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY IN DISARRAY,
BEING CHAOTIC.
THEY DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT
DIRECTION THEY'RE GOING IN.
>> Laura: HICKENLOOPER,
BULLOCK FROM MONTANA.
VARIOUS POINTS IN TIME, THEY
BASHED TRUMP.
THEY HAVE TO.
BUT I LOOKED AT THEM GOING GOSH,
IF HE ONLY WORKED WITH THE
PRESIDENT ON SOME OF THESE
ISSUES, YOU COULD PROBABLY
ACCOMPLISH A LOT.
AND TIM RYAN WAS TOTALLY UP ON
TRADE BECAUSE HE'S OHIO.
HE'S LIKE, I DON'T WANT TO
ANSWER ON STEEL TARIFFS.
THEY ARE BOXED IN ON THE WORKING
CLASS VOTER.
I SAW THAT REPEATEDLY.
THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> NO QUESTION THEY'RE MAKING A
PLAY FOR THE UNION VOTERS.
YOU SAW TRUMP GO OUT AND GIVE
THE PREDEBATE SPEECH.
AT ONE POINT I WAS ASKING
MYSELF, IS HE --
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS REALLY HONED
IN ON HELPING THE AMERICAN
WORKER.
THIS IS WHY WE'VE SEEN A BOOM
WHEN IT COMES TO MANUFACTURING
JOBS.
YOU'VE SEEN WAGES INCREASE AND
ITS INCREASED PARTICULARLY FOR
BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS.
THE PRESIDENT, BECAUSE HE'S BEEN
STRONG ON TRADE, STRONG AGAINST
CHINA BEING THE BAD ACTOR, IT
BENEFITED THE AMERICAN WORKER.
THE DEMOCRATS, THEY DON'T EVEN
HAVE A COHERENT LINE OF WHERE
THEY ARE HEADED WITH THE
AMERICAN WORKER WHICH IS I THINK
TROUBLING FOR THEM AND THEIR
ONLY SOLUTION IS LET'S GET MORE
GOVERNMENT INVOLVED.
LET'S GET MAKE SURE YOU GET FREE
HEALTH CARE.
WE CAN GET HER WAGES UP, THAT'S
GREAT.
>> Laura: ONE OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT KEPT SAYING IS WE
NEED TO WORK MORE WITH THE E.U.
TO PUT PRESSURE ON CHINA.
I'M THINKING WHAT DO THEY THINK
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN DOING?
THE ANSWER TO SO MUCH OF WHAT
THEY SAID TONIGHT IS, AND
CERTAINLY TOMORROW WITH BIDEN,
YOU HAD EIGHT YEARS.
THESE IDEAS ARE SO OBVIOUS AND
YOU COULD HAVE TRANSFORMED
ECONOMY, WHAT, WHAT, WHAT, WHERE
WAS THAT?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ALSO MADE
THE COMMENT OF BERNIE HAS BEEN
THE ONE AGAINST NAFTA AND     AD
THE ONE AGAINST NAFTA AND     AT
THE ONE AGAINST NAFTA AND     AE
ONE AGAINST TPP.
REMEMBER, WE STILL HAVE USMCA
THAT IS STUCK IN CONGRESS
BECAUSE NANCY PELOSI HASN'T
MOVED IT FORWARD.
YOU HAVE DEMOCRATS COME YOU SEE
MORE CHAOS, MORE DIVISION.
NOT AGREEING ON THE POLICIES BUT
THE POLICIES THAT ARE A OUT THE
LOUDEST ARE THE MORE RADICAL
ONES.
MEDICARE FOR ALL IS GOING TO BE
TREMENDOUSLY COSTLY IN WE KNOW
THEY'RE GOING TO INCREASE TAXES
ON THE MIDDLE CLASS.
>> Laura: EACH STUMBLED EXCEPT
FOR BETO.
HE'S JUST IN FANTASYLAND.
>> WARREN SAID THAT TOO.
>> Laura: SHE SET OVERALL.
SHE DODGED IT.
OVERALL THE COST WILL GO UP.
MERCEDES, I WANT TO GET YOUR
REACTION TO CNN'S LATEST FOCUS
GROUP FIASCO.
>> HOW MANY OF YOU ARE
OPTIMISTIC THAT IT DEMOCRAT WILL
WIN IN 2020?
>> I THINK A BLIND OPTIMISM IS
HOW WE GOT TRUMP.
WE REALLY NEEDED CANDIDATES IT'S
GOING TO INCREASE DEMOCRATIC
TURNOUT AND NOT THE CANDIDATE
IT'S GOING TO CONVINCE TRUMP
VOTERS TO VOTE FOR THEM BECAUSE
IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> I'M USUALLY OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
A LOT OF THINGS BUT I'M AFRAID
OF THIS NEXT ELECTION.
>> Laura: OF COURSE WE FIND
OUT THAT DETROIT IS ACTUALLY
DOING LITTLE BIT BETTER,
MICHIGAN IS DOING BETTER, A LOT
OF IT, BECAUSE OF TRUMP
POLICIES, TRADE POLICIES AND SO
FORTH.
>> LOOK, I REALLY THINK THE
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO FIND
THEIR PLAYER, THE PERSON THEY
THINK CAN WIN.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT TO FOCUS
ON.
THEIR OPTIONS ARE THOSE THAT
WILL JUST TAKE AMERICA FAR TO
THE LEFT.
HER YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT THAT'S
BEEN RESULT ORIENTED,
COMMON SENSE, PRACTICAL.
>> Laura: TAKE THE TEMPERATURE
DOWN, RIGHT?
THE TEMPERATURE HAS GOT TO COME
DOWN.
SUBURBAN WOMEN, YOU DO WANT THEM
TO TURNOUT.
I THINK A LOT OF THEM DO LIKE
THE PRESIDENT BUT THE
TEMPERATURE CAN'T STAY HOT, HOT,
HOT ALL THE TIME.
>> THE HYPOCRISY OF THE
DEMOCRATS SAY THAT THEY WANT TO
SECURE THE BORDER YET THEY HAVE
DONE NOTHING ON THE HILL.
>> Laura: I THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD GO INTO
BALTIMORE FOR FOUR OR FIVE
PUBLIC-SECTOR, PRIVATE-SECTOR
FOLKS AND IN A WEEK COME UP WITH
FIVE POLICIES THAT HAVE WORKED
ELSEWHERE.
JUST SAY TRY THESE.
TRY THESE.
I'LL HELP YOU.
>> HE IS STARTING WITH
OPPORTUNITY ZONES, INVESTMENT,
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM, MOVING
TOWARDS SCHOOL CHOICE NOT JUST
ALLOW FOR THESE BROKEN SCHOOLS.
WE HAVE POLICIES THAT WE KNOW
ARE GOING TO WORK.
THE QUESTION IS THE DEMOCRAT
LEADERSHIP THAT'S BEEN INGRAINED
IN THE CITIES, THESE URBAN
CITIES, ARE THEY WILLING TO TRY
NEW WAYS INSTEAD OF STICKING TO
THE STATUS QUO?
>> Laura: THE PODCAST TODAY, I
WOULD GO AROUND ELIJAH CUMMINGS
TO THE PEOPLE, THE DISRUPTORS ON